chief White House correspondent John
Roberts is here on the North Lawn to
Phyllis and good evening John I was
going to say bringing back memories
chilly the theme for tonight's address
is building a safe strong and proud
America and to do that President Trump
tonight will attempt to open an
engagement across the aisle with
Democrats upbeat and uplifting is how
White House officials are describing
president Trump's first State of the
Union address after a year of rancorous
partisan bickering and polarizing
legislation President Trump will reach
out across the aisle at a lunch with TV
anchors the president saying I want to
see our country united it was divided
not just under President Obama or
President Bush I remember the
impeachment of Bill Clinton tremendous
divisive nough Stover the past year if I
could unite this country I would
consider it a tremendous success the
press secretary says tonight's speech
will be a personal appeal his stage and
his time to talk directly to the
American people and I think you're gonna
see a lot of the President himself come
through in his words at the State of the
Union tonight so where are we with the
speeches five main themes jobs in the
economy the latest jobless rate held
steady at four point one percent
african-american unemployment dropped to
a historic low of six point eight
percent but still nearly double the
white unemployment rate of three point
seven fourth-quarter GDP dropped to two
point six percent still relatively
strong but nowhere near what the
president promised during the campaign
that's why I believe it's time to
establish a national goal of reaching
four percent economic growth on
infrastructure the president hopes to
build bipartisan support for a 1.7
trillion dollar plan but Democrat Chuck
Schumer is skeptical in an op-ed writing
the president promised a trillion dollar
investment in our infrastructure on the
campaign trail but since he took the
oath of office Congress hasn't heard
much about his plan and what we have
heard isn't promising immigration is the
most difficult agenda item congressional
Republicans hope to have the framework
of a deal by February 9th when the
government again runs out of money a
deal that could expand beyond the
president's four core principles of a
fix for daca a border wall and an end to
chain migration and the diverse
a visa lottery on trade President Trump
will continue to promote his
america-first policies seeking free fair
and reciprocal trade and on national
security Fox News is told the president
will be tough on North Korea one White
House officials saying it may be the
most memorable part of the speech after
missing the trip to Davos First Lady
Melania Trump will be there tonight
along with Ivanka Eric and Donald Trump
jr. and she will have at least 14
special guests among them an Ohio welder
the parents of two girls murdered by
ms-13 gang members a young man who
placed flags and flowers on forty
thousand veterans graves and a blind
double amputee Marine who Rhian listed
the White House tweeting a photo of
corporal Matthew Bradford meeting the
president in the Oval Office the
Democrats are fielding a half a dozen
responses to the Republicans Congressman
Joe Kennedy the third of Massachusetts
will give the official response but
there's a handful of others as well one
involving celebrities that occurred last
night and Bernie Sanders from Vermont
will also give his response to the
president's State of the Union it's
going to be a long night Brett they will
and then no expectation that he's gonna
mention the investigation no why would
you want to do that that would that
would probably just take the attention
off what it is that you really want to
get out there the thing that I'm
interested in because you'll remember
last year he when he gave the address to
a joint meeting of Congress literally
the next day that got blown off the
headlines because Jeff Sessions recused
himself is there something that's laying
in wait to take the spotlight away from
the president tomorrow we'll stay we
will see John thank you